[Música]
vamos a profundizar en esa noticia que
les dábamos al inicio este informativo
sobre ese embargo el petróleo ruso por
parte de la unión europea las aquí la
información la tiene jorge hurtado en el
estudio de france 24 muchas gracias
jorge por acompañarnos que más detalles
al respecto
bueno como sabrán este veto llevaba casi
un mes estancado en la comisión europea
precisamente por la alta dependencia que
tienen varios países de europa al
petróleo ruso las sanciones ahora
prohibiría en la compra de crudo y
productos petrolíferos procedentes de
rusia entregados por vía marítima esto
según charlas mich el presidente del
consejo europeo la medida también
exonera temporalmente los hidrocarburos
que viajan por oleoductos esto fue
pensado precisamente para países como
hungría república checa eslovaquia o
austria que no tienen salida al mar y
que solamente pueden recibir los
hidrocarburos por gasoductos y
oleoductos las sanciones también
incluyen excluyen del sistema financiero
swift a otros tres bancos rusos este
veto al petróleo ruso costaría casi 70
mil millones de euros a las finanzas de
moscú anualmente la dependencia europea
es tal que el bloque ha pagado a rusia
32 mil 300 millones de dólares por
petróleo desde el 24 febrero que fue
precisamente el día cuando inició la
guerra europa es el mayor mercado de
rusia para las exportaciones de petróleo
de los 47 millones de barriles diarios
de crudo que exporta rusia la mitad van
para la unión europea según la agencia
internacional de energía esto trae a
repercusiones mientras estaba este
diálogo allá en bruselas obviamente los
precios se dispararon 120 dólares por
brasil por barril de petróleo a nivel
internacional el precio más alto de
hecho en casi dos meses los contratos de
futuros del brent para julio subieron
más de un 0,58 por ciento se ubicaron en
121 dólares el barril por su parte los
futuros del west texas en estados unidos
ganaron 82 centavos o un 0.71 rondaban
los 115 dólares el barril una nueva
prohibición del petróleo ruso va a
tensar evidentemente el mercado del
crudo que ya está sometido una gran
presión en cuanto a la oferta en un
contexto de aumento de la demanda de
gasolina diésel y carburante para
aviones especialmente la organización de
países exportadores de petróleo y sus
aliados entre los que se encuentra rusia
se reunirán el jueves para rechazar las
peticiones de occidente para acelerar el
aumento de la producción mundial de
petróleo porque mientras hay más sanción
es hacia rusia y hacia su petróleo este
país está aumentando sus reservas de
cereales en medio precisamente de este
conflicto nuclear ya y también cuando
crece sobre todo las preocupaciones por
una posible crisis alimentaria a nivel
global la guerra en ucrania ha
interrumpido las entregas de trigo y
otros productos básicos en ambos países
que representan alrededor del 30 por
ciento y el 20 por ciento de las
exportaciones mundiales de trigo y maíz
pero arcadi es el esquí quien es
presidente del sindicato de cereales de
rusia dijo que las reservas actuales son
20 por ciento más que el año pasado el
gobierno ruso dijo que la cosecha de
esta temporada podría batir un récord
histórico escuchamos
nuestros suministros son casi un 20 por
ciento superiores a los del año pasado
en lugar de abastecer el mercado mundial
estamos reponiendo nuestros propios
ministros no estamos reduciendo o
limitando nuestras entregas al exterior
de ninguna manera hasta el final de la
temporada aunque al final serán unos 5
millones menos que el potencial de
exportación este pulso veremos ahora
nuestra región américa latina porque
ayer fueron definidos los dos candidatos
que van a ir a la segunda vuelta
presidencial en colombia que proponen
ellos en materia económica jorge bueno
santiago pensamos con el que resta a
gustavo petro a nivel de impuestos pero
busca que aumenten los ingresos por
medio de una nueva reforma fiscal él
espera recaudar 20 millones de pesos
quiere aumentar el tamaño del recaudo en
5% del producto interno bruto no tocaría
dijo el impuesto al valor agregado
aunque lo aumentaría así para alimentos
que según él no son nutritivos a nivel
de pensiones quiere unificar el sistema
de pensiones en colombia ahora mismo es
mixto público y privado él quiere que
sean mayoritariamente público por su
parte de su oponente el empresario
rodolfo hernández propone de un estatuto
tributario territorial así lo ha llamado
esto para aumentar los ingresos
tributarios sin nuevas reformas
tributarias a nivel de pensiones quiere
aumentar los subsidios pensionales para
personas de escasos recursos y brindar
un salario mínimo mensual a quienes no
alcancen a pensionarse jorge muchas
gracias por esta actualización del mundo
de la economía es todo por el momento
aquí en el franz 24 los invito a
continuación a el debate
[Música]